[Music]
eeen is bad for you new delicious food
go ahead oh the minute bye
who are you who are you who the hell do
you think you are good study concludes
that toxic co-workers may actually be
harmful to your health yes I agree I
agree I agree yet yeah a Haunter person
and get right there because yes not only
dr. Koch toxic human beings in your life
affects every little [ __ ] thing your
sleep your act without my appetite yeah
but dude like it's just like it's it's
the stress level it just takes
everything out of you man gosh hey
there's energy sucker you know the five
people closest to you our reflection of
who you are so one of those people you
don't want to be like them take them out
of real life yeah I gotta get new
friends
this'll [ __ ] cold-blooded
we're in the Holyrood I'm just kidding
because you know I immediately thought
does any of you run like a gazelle nope
I gotta get a gazelle friend any of you
strong like a gorilla
well maybe Bart my girls are still
stronger I want to go a friend
they are my strong feels like a gazelle
yeah yeah yeah but compared to an actual
gazelle you can't do that and anyone
swim like a dolphin my god hahaha
Michael can Michael can't swim like I
seen any what you need in our animal
friends I need just all animals as
friends like beefmaster can i still be
your friend now cuz that's fun yeah but
there'll be my five closest and then I
pictured myself in the forest with a
hawk on my shoulder a dolphin on my side
there's a guy open come in this bar open
don't have to know they're not gonna die
take a breathe air yeah but I guess
that's honor yeah
they live in water so their skins gonna
get eczema okay you're a cruel friend
great they're going to get rid of you
something based in reality and put into
a different world I thought I want to do
the display:none important anyway so
there's this recent study
it's called targeted workplace in
civility the roles of belongingness
embarrassment and power that's the whole
time I'm too [ __ ] long so dumb so
it's really good our city of Calgary's
Heskey me school of business and London
School of Economics and political
science I got a better name for it the
office dick face there you go that
sucker that always brings problems to
work takes it out on their co-workers
not knowingly sometimes knowingly being
a such a mother ass like they just need
their diaper changed you know what I'm
talking about yeah so if they found is
that people that work with toxic
co-workers experience alarms physical
symptoms like for example headache
stomach problems and like high blood
pressure
Thank You Kenny murderous thoughts
guitar dorestad yeah they just take it
with you and like you can never let it
go because then you take it home with
you in the damage your very life
everything inside on everything cuz
these are the people like the 905 hours
they spend the most time yes these
people yeah you go home any go to sleep
yeah I remember when I used to work in a
company that's the main thing I hated I
always hated like having to get along
and pretend yeah because I will try in
the beginning but after a while I just
said no I can't do it I cannot I cannot
work like this and then I sabotage them
and get them fired or you know what's
interesting though I remember this is
like the same thing that not only goes
in the workplace for you kids out there
the same thing with people in high
school and the people you hang out with
same thing did those those dude in high
school used to always say the same
[ __ ] joke every day used to annoy the
[ __ ] out of me you would say the same
joke he goes hey man you want to you
want to see these the basically he was
referring to his nuts and he would say
that joke every day and
you will laugh right so one day I looked
at them people you want CDs there that
your own time but to Mister hey shut the
[ __ ] up nobody likes you like that
because what you got probably I was like
dude he was oh by the way I heard you
like talking [ __ ] about me as I dude I
talk [ __ ] to your face every day of
course obviously behind your back so
what are you talking about I'm a
consistent person yeah
what are you surprised what the [ __ ]
every day I wake up and I pray to the
car hits you but you're still here so I
don't understand how many of you guys
have had real corporate job uh kind of a
kind of like office jobs yeah I used to
work in an office to office jobs are
[ __ ] movie job the girl there made me
feel so dumb that I couldn't even trust
myself that's how I felt that how do
they make you feel dumb they just like
like I'm a type of person that likes to
step outside of my box I like do extra
things for the team but my manager would
keep telling me that's not what you were
hired for do what you were hired for
like that because you would think like a
buck that's exactly what happened to man
although yes they're like oh you can
take my job [ __ ] no I don't want to take
your job babymaker smaller exactly like
we're working let me just make life
easier by doing something like that's
going to be way more efficient for us
but they're like nah that's how we've
been doing it this is how we do things
politics doesn't let you let them see
you like that red tape everywhere you
know what the crazy thing if they were
smart I'll be like James please do more
I'm just gonna take all the credit right
but they're not part of it not smarter
yeah dude I remember this one guy so he
was he was doing data entry right he
would copy and paste every single cell
to the next cell I'm like why don't you
highlight the whole [ __ ] thing open
up a new page and copy and paste in one
go it goes because that's not what I was
taught to do I was taught to do the guys
I asked you how to do this doesn't know
how to use Excel
that's why he taught you how to do that
and then they're like nah but I have to
do it this way talk to the manager yeah
that's how we were taught so we have to
do it that way just highlight the whole
[ __ ] cell and now you have to waste a
manager's time on that [ __ ] yeah hey can
eat copy and paste this whole thing yes
and I have to go back and talk to the
system in migraine didn't like the whole
politics
- because I remember dealing with a lot
of co-workers on that when I worked in
the hospital they were so like oh I'm
like dude I'm the youngest one here I
was 19 when I was working there everyone
else like the second youngest person was
like in the 30-ton like you guys are
grown-ass adults and like you're in high
school like I just left high school it
wasn't as bad as this Wow is that you
know one of the things that I do like
the most though is solids in the Marines
and there's a different type of
corporate coat that they follow
especially the old Corps I don't know
how the new Chorus and there's this guy
he was I think like 24 25 when I first
came in I was like 19 and because you've
such a [ __ ] bag I started getting
promoted and eventually when he was my
senior by the time I was in for like
four or five years I was a senior Wow
and then my manager or my boss at the
time he was trying to make in Utah and
he gets Santiago and order of the fusion
is making our entire department look bad
so I pulled them to the side in our
warehouse and I'm like look you're one
of the seniors I hear you've been here
for seven years and we're always
carrying away I pretty much gave him a
very cordial type of talk and then
afterwards I said and if you don't do it
I'm off lock your ass up but I would
literally beat the [ __ ] out of you right
now I love that and then but that's
accepted you know that's that's a marine
that's accepted in that corporate hard
luck and I wish that could exist because
if he actually ratted me out huh every
single marine would think that either
[ __ ] like whistle blowing in that
regard we considered a [ __ ] and so I
wish that a lot of corporate cultures to
be like that Andy but if that happened
in like like let's say actual corporate
America I like a Wall Street company or
something like Sears bringing your
students like a [ __ ] that's why
you have to get a black mask and beat
them up in front of our house yeah so
they don't know who you just Peruvian to
make me so sad owes Peru and Peru that's
why you hire immigrants because they
won't sue you that's right yeah we had a
connection I knew there's something
wrong when you go into the Marine Corps
and there's a guy that's wearing green
contacts okay cream contact brown eyes
were in green contact in the military
there's something wrong with this guy
any other dealt with the co-worker so
that was so toxic that like it would
really affect you so much and you take
it home
toxic managers well I had that yeah
never really co-workers because I didn't
have anyone that was really an equal
that made me feel like I hate you
because if they're equal to me I can
just talk to them about it stop being a
dick or whatever I don't know but then
when they're superior I think that's
when it's really like ah you know who
you report him to here because their
division of power yeah because there are
certain things like they're not doing
anything wrong but the way they talk to
you the tone of voice yeah they don't
say hey can you please get that duggle
go get that and then you can't really
report things like right and if you
stand up for yourself you look like a
sensitive [ __ ] right but it's like dude
man what's up I ain't dealing with those
people when they do it like they do
enough to get under your skin but it's
not enough for you really like yeah and
it's big enough cuz then you end up
looking like them you know it's all so
dope about the military back in the old
core if you have beef with their manager
you guys can take your ranks off go in
the back and fight like two dudes
yes actually all the way put the ranks
back on yes sir no sir so I had this
really shitty manager right this was in
a corporate gig but this was a in a
restaurant and then like in when I first
started you know I want to be I just
want to do my best right so she abused
her power by saying she was showing off
to her other waiters like hey watch this
hey Joe go give me a big bowl I scream
and I'm like okay cool no problem huh
you know and I went and got a big bowl
of ice cream I gave it to her and she
was laughing just to show that I do
things for her
and I was like you like huh if she just
wanted ice cream
no problem I'll do it but I was in the
middle being and I was busy as hell but
I also handled that for her too right
and I was like after that I talked to my
other co-workers and they're like dude
no you're not going to get fired next
time just tell her no you could always
say no so then next time when she was
really [ __ ] busy and stressed things
who can't take care of this table and
I'm like nope Haho and she couldn't
reform she couldn't do anything yeah
but here's the other thing I [ __ ]
really started hating her right so she
got drunk on the job and then I actually
helped getting her more and more alcohol
she got really [ __ ] wasted and then I
reported her ass to the other managers
and then they had to [ __ ] fire her
what a [ __ ] I'm a sabotaging
[ __ ] too maybe he was a toxic Oh
[Laughter]
what of all my positive people I want to
hear your thoughts put it in the
comments below because if you're
negative shut the hell up and go drink
some raid please but if you're very
positive leave it in the comments below
for the last video here
[Music]